[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tb 78
l'émission à ne pas manquer si vous êtes
un passionné de sport local c'est le 7-8
sport c'est parti pour le sommaire de ce
magazine breakdance pour la troisième
fois l'ultimate battle master accueilli
des artistes et athlètes du monde entier
pour s'affronter à l'occasion d'un
rendez vous situez d'habitude à
aubergenville la compétition s'est
déroulée cette fois ci au forum armand
peugeot de poissy au reportage danse
classique ce sport est encore cette
année l'un des plus plébiscité lors des
forums des associations
comment expliquer à cet engouement nous
sommes allés du côté de saint cyr
l'école dans une structure de danse
voile louis burton skipper de
rambouillet va participer à la prochaine
édition de la transat jacques vabre le
troisième du dernier vendée globe
naviguera avec son ami davy beaudart les
détails dans ce magazine l'actualité
sportive c'est maintenant sur tv 68
[Musique]
on va donc commencer par du break dance
pour la troisième fois l' ultimate
battle master accueilli des artistes
athlètes du monde entier pour
s'affronter sur ce futur sport olympique
la compétition s'est déroulée à poissy
devant un jury à d'experts en reportage
de bixente mérian santisteva
[Musique]
ferait de gala opposant armand peugeot à
poissy ultimate battle masters c'est
l'une des compétitions émergentes du
breakdance cette année c'est une équipe
française qui a remporté le titre
c'était assez rude parce que c'était sûr
du temps lui minutes 10 minutes 10
minutes c'est ça demande beaucoup de
temps beaucoup d'énergie surtout que
on n'était pas préparé à ça mais
on a su quand même
bien bien relever la pente et
on a pu gagner cette compétition et on
est très fier de moi et mon équipe une
belle performance dans le niveau était
élevé avec des équipes venues du monde
entier parce qu'on a pu voir ce soir ça
fait partie de l'excellence mondiale
que ce soit le continent européen le
continent africain le continent
américain voilà ils étaient tous
représentés c'est actuellement ce qui se
fait quasiment de mieux pour encadrer
les athlètes un jury de prestige jury
que j'ai choisi sévèrement à la crème au
niveau de hauts niveaux de débits bois
et français on n'a eu qu'à lille qui est
champion de france on a eu l'idée est
qu'il est triple champion du monde et on
a eu ce aussi une figure emblématique du
bowling français et qui est aussi
champion de france donc on a et vice
champion du monde
du côté des moins de 16 ans l'italien
bboy dunger a gagné la finale face au
français le qui je suis un peu déçu
d'avoir perdu en finale mais là je vais
m'entraîner pour gagner la prochaine
fois peut-être le break dance et ont
désormais une discipline olympique l'
ultimate battle master souhaite
s'inscrire dans les tournois
préparatoires en vue de paris 2024
lui ne sera pas aligné sur les épreuves
de braindead breakdance en 2024 mais il
devrait être présent dans l'est à bassin
aux jeux paralympiques de paris cet été
à tokyo alex portal le nageur de
saint-germain-en-laye remporté une
médaille d'argent et une médaille de
bronze interview express avec le sportif
de 19 ans regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là où j'ai pu se réaliser que j'avais
fait des belles choses ces camps quand
j'étais sur le podium
surtout au 200 m 4 nages où on voit le
drapeau de la france qui s'élève à près
si aussi sur le retour quand on est avec
toute la délégation dans l'avion tous
les français ils sont là dans l'avion
profiter et après à notre arrivée en
france à l' aéroport on a on a été
escorté jusqu'à l'hôtel de ville par la
police partie des choses qui arrive très
rarement voire jamais du coup c'était
une super expérience et et de voir à
l'hôtel de ville en fait on a fait la
passation du drapeau pour paris 2024 la
livre à pau paralympiques et du coup de
voir tout ce monde qui sont venus nous
voir nous on nous dira bravo et nous
encourager et nous soutenir ça fait oui
ça fait d'ailleurs de là on se rend
compte que on a vécu quelque chose
d'extraordinaire
il reste trois ans trois entraînements
pour pour essayer de viser l'or
manière ya que ça qui marche
d'entraînement il ya que ça qui
fonctionnera donc
je retournerais lalo le 4 octobre pour
enchaîner sur une c'est sur une saison
qui se finira par les chapelles du monde
en juin à pau portugal et après on aura
deux autres saisons également pour
préparer paris où là j'espère faire
champion paralympique et gagner le titre
[Musique]
normalement c'est pas dans mes projets
de l'équité surtout que c'est c'est
c'est dans à côté d'eux à côté du club
les les jeux et voilà je pense que ça
fait bien longtemps que je suis avec eux
ils s'initient ça marche bien ça
fonctionne bien donc il n'y a pas deux
il ya pas de raison pour le moment nous
allons maintenant passer aux résultats
sportifs du week-end dans les yvelines
pour m'accompagner bixente mérian
santisteva nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
bonsoir bixente 6 ans michael alors
chacun dit vous nous proposez un tour
d'horizon du coup des résultats sportifs
du week-end dans les yvelines on va tout
de suite commencé à part du football oui
michael est la huitième journée de
nationale 2 les versaillais poursuivre
leur série d'invincibilité par un nul 0
0 face à granville versailles est
troisième avec 14 points à trois
longueurs plus bas poissy qui a tenu en
échec les deuxièmes du championnat blois
foot un partout l'épi siècle et se place
à la 9e place du classement on descend
de quelques divisions à présent avec de
la régionale 2 mais un derby yvelinois
entre n'offre aux chartrains ouille les
audois sont sortis vainqueurs sur un
score net de 0 une deuxième victoire en
autant de matchs pour ou qui se place en
tête du classement une bonne semaine
pour le club après avoir appris son
repêchage en coupe de france quant à 9
cette première défaite en championnat
tombe mal une semaine après
l'élimination en coupe nationale au
niveau départemental la première
division a repris ce week end oui
mickaël une reprise avec peu de scores
serrés puisque toutes les équipes ont
gagné avec deux buts d'écart minimum
trois victoires à domicile d'abord avec
un 2 0 pour le ch est né qui recevait
vallée 78 ou deux contres bois d'arcy ça
donnait 3 et sartrouville qui
l'emportent 3 0 face à voisins bailly
noisy et carrière grésillons se sont
imposés respectivement sur les pelouses
de gargenville et d'aubergenville seul
but les épaules se sont neutralisés sur
un score vierge 0 à 0 du basket à
présent avec un week-end qui a peu souri
à nos équipes yvelinoise oui en
nationale 3 l'entente le
chesnay-versailles s'éteint né dans la
poule f contre saint laurent de la
plaine défaite 60 à 72 de journée pour
deux défaites tout comme lui as marly le
roi qui a perdu contre bayeux 51,72
seule trappe parvient à enchaîner en
terre normande les trappistes confirment
leur bon début de saison par une
victoire 58 53 contre l'union caen
hérouville basket on passe au rugby et
plaisir qui s'incline en fédérale 2 oui
alors que le plaisir rugby club nourrit
de grandes ambitions dans cette division
s'est déjà pour eux une deuxième défaite
en trois journées en déplacement au
havre les plaisirs one n'ont pas pu
contenir les attaques adverses et
concède 43 points pour seulement 23
points inscrits en fédérale 3 le
championnat a repris ce week-end
également une première journée qui aura
vu deux victoires à l'extérieur pour les
clubs du département versailles s'impose
face à un autre pensionnaire des
yvelines où ils 37 à 25 quant à
l'entente maisons laffitte saint germain
poissy elle s'impose également largement
à cergy 30 à 7 4 essais synonymes de
bonus offensif pour le club et par la
même occasion d'une première place du
championnat handball féminin maintenant
oui et montigny le bretonneux qui
poursuit son bon début de saison à
draveil pour une victoire 23 à 19 les
minimes antennes sont troisièmes du
classement avec deux victoires et une
défaite elles recevront le club d'issy
paris au prochain match du tennis à
présent et arthur rinderknecht qui n'a
pas brillé au tournoi de metz c'était
mardi dernier le 74 ème joueur mondial a
été battu au premier tour par
l'américain marcos gérone il avait
pourtant accroché la première manche 6 3
avant d'être renversée 7-6 6-4
l'yvelinois sera cette semaine au
challenger d'orléans premier match
demain contre antoine wang 155e mondial
ou on vous tient au courant la semaine
prochaine enfin en clôture notre page
résultats par l'un des événements du
week-end dans les yvelines mantes la
jolie accueilli les championnats de
france d'aviron et parmi les résultats
notables les champions olympiques
mathieu androdias hugo boucheron ont
décroché le titre national dans
l'épreuve reine le bateau unis le 8
appelé aussi bateau roi médaillé
d'argent aux jeux olympiques de tokyo
l'été dernier lé yvelinoise clairvaux v
a pris la 3e place du deux de couple
accompagné de sa paire julie domine ce
qui pour le club de l'asptt nantes merci
à bixente pour toutes ces précisions on
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine en
forme exactement en forme toujours il y
avait également de la course à pied ce
week-end avec la 15e édition de la
foulée celle en courtoise ce dimanche 26
septembre au matin 480 courant âgées de
plus de 15 ans ont pris le départ du 10
km depuis le stade michaud du chez nero
concours au programme un parcours dans
l'arboretum de versailles chèvreloup à
travers les arbres on écoute les
réactions au micro de justin brazy une
course familiale une course nature je
pense que voilà les pouvoirs viennent
prendre du plaisir pas forcément une
performance honnête course mais surtout
du plaisir c'est un grand plaisir d'être
au départ ce matin avec toutes ces
personnes avec qui on va partager le
bonheur de pouvoir recourir sans trop de
contraintes voilà et surtout à le
plaisir de faire du sport voilà en
loisir peut être en compétition mais
surtout aux loisirs pour rester en forme
allez au revoir
on voit louis burton a décidé de tester
son nouveau bateau bureau vallée 3 sur
la transat jacques vabre il partira au
mois de novembre avec son ami des vies à
bodart pour cette course transatlantique
en duo des images de patrick jacques de
dixmude
louis burton participera une nouvelle
fois la transat jacques vabre le skipper
originaire de rambouillet seront au
départ de cette 15e édition avec son
bureau vallée 3 le navigator aura pour
objectif de terminer dans le top 5 de
cette course transatlantique qui reliera
le havre à la martinique on a le bateau
pour cette année on aura quand même pu
naviguer pas mal avec on a nos sponsors
et donc dur vallée en tête qui nous
permettent de faire un nouveau jeu de
voiles qui nous permettent de vraiment
préparé notre bateau donc on vise un top
5 et on rêve on rêve secrètement de
monter sur le podium - pour sa sixième
participation louis burton partir avec
son ami de longue date davy beaudart un
skipper qui devrait lui permettre de
remplir ses objectifs on est déjà parti
ensemble avec des vues en 2019 c'est un
ami ça c'est sûr depuis très longtemps
mais c'est aussi un grand champion
puisqu'il a il a gagné énormément
énormément de courses dans toute sa
carrière et puis c'est quelqu'un qui a
une grande compétence dans le
développement technique des bateaux et
et
et donc on est assez complémentaires sur
ces aspects là et ça se passe très bien
sur l'eau on se complète heures avant la
course et sur l'eau on fait tout
ensemble le départ de la transat jacques
vabre est programmée le 7 novembre
prochain à 13h30 direction à les
antilles pour la flotte
coup de projecteur à présent sur une
discipline indémodable la danse
classique avec plus de 4000 adhérents et
3 millions de pratiquants dans toute la
france ce sport est encore cette année
l'un des plus a plébiscité lors des
forums des associations
comment expliquer cet engouement nous
sommes allés du côté de saint cyr
l'école dans une structure de danse en
montage de lucas audard
et demi pointes
[Musique]
l'autre pièce aujourd'hui comme souvent
ce cours de danse classique haas ancien
l'école est bien remplie dans le
complexe sportif pierre mazeaud une
vingtaine de danseuses s'essaye aux
cabrioles au pas chasser ou encore aux
changements pied une véritable passion
pour ces sportives c'est sympa et
c'est une bonne occupation cup en plus
je vois mes copines préféré s'y colle
décider
des grands gestes comme ça vous ai
trouvé une ovation et je trouvais donc
classique et quand j'ai commencé il y
avait déjà mes amis et tout ça je me
suis dit que ça pourrait être cool j'ai
continué ça nous occupe à au lieu de
rester à la maison a écrit roi regarder
la télé en france on compte près de 80
mille adhérents dont plusieurs milliers
dans les yvelines des chiffres en
augmentation depuis plusieurs années
dans cette structure de saint cyr
l'école créée en 2015 les inscriptions
doublé en six ans pour passer à 150
adhérents sur la danse classique la
rigueur de la matière
l'expérience scénique également on
apprend deux choses essentiellement un
travail purement techniques que vous
avez pu voir par exemple un travail
de position deux jambes deux bras et un
travail artistique
on a beaucoup d'imaginaire et
d'expression qui est mis en jeu dans le
travail chorégraphique un apprentissage
qui commence dès le plus jeune âge ici à
saint cyr l'école on peut débuter dès 3
ans
on passe maintenant notre page agenda
on commence cet agenda par duo rugby
c'est la reprise pour le championnat
honneur le club de l'union rues
glissantes soixante dix huit jours a
pour son premier match de la saison sur
le terrain de paris ce dimanche à 15
heures les îles du nord ont à coeur de
commencer par une victoire eux qui
cherchent une place sur le podium en fin
de saison chevreuse de son côté ira sur
le terrain de créteil choisi pour
débuter sa saison en honneur en football
on connaît a désormais les affiches du
4e tour de la coupe de france le tirage
au sort a été effectué mercredi dernier
où il se déplacera sur le terrain de
saint michel pour l'entrée en lice
versailles recevra brétigny et poissy se
rendra à gré de ce tournant les mureaux
accueilleront fleury chatou irak ainsi
hardricourt à champagne 95 trappe
affrontera le plus que voisins aura fort
à faire face à courbevoie club de
régionale 2 tout comme plaisir qui
jouera contre le racing chambourcy
affrontera villeneuve ablon enfin le
petit poucet des yvelines bréval on y
recevra vincennes les matches sont
programmés dès samedi 2 et dimanche 3
octobre hommes et on termine par un
rendez vous insolites les championnats
de france de dragon boat sont
programmées ce samedi dimanche sur le
stade nautique international didier
simon à mantes-la-jolie ce sport
nautique d'equipe se déroule à bord
d'une pirogue et il faut avancer avec
l'aide des bras le plus rapidement
possible si vous voulez assister à ce
rendez-vous l'entrée est libre c'est la
fin de cette émission à merci d'avoir
suivi on se retrouve bientôt pour un
nouveau magazine à 10 il a passé une
excellente semaine sportive à bientôt
sur tv 78
[Musique]